hi I'm Monica the beauty expert I'm
Ashley the coordination maven and today
we're gonna have one woman avoid a
quarter life crisis Patrice
tell us about your quarter life crisis I
recently got a job as a producer
congratulations but I just feel like I
want to be taken seriously and I feel
like there are a couple challenges with
that one I look really young I noticed
that if I look like a kid people treat
me like a kid usually I'm a lot more
Street kind of workout clothes do you
feel like you have any pieces that are a
little more like businessí
I do and they literally have cobwebs on
them I haven't had to wear them in such
a long time so that's where any chick
guess is hell but you sound super ready
you're doing the work on the inside it's
time to address the outside so we're
coming over oh okay declutter and
organize leave it the way it is be
yourself and just let us help you
upgrade it a little bit where are you
coming get to say the real okay you have
so much to work with already just like
right off the bat you're already so
close to where you're trying to be so I
definitely have some tips and ideas for
you so my skincare and I would love to
talk about because I literally just
washed my face with a soy cleanser and
then I don't do anything else cuz I have
really oily skin you are saying that you
don't own any moisturizer that is I knew
your eye on estanzuela skin it feels
super like counterintuitive to put
product on top of that but actually
moisturizers are like it keeps the oil
in your skin and keeps me hydrated so I
have a product that I'm gonna recommend
to you it's the Olay Total Effects 7 in
one moisturizer you
keep it simple and get your oh yeah all
from this girl so this is my work space
is a little crazy but I kind of wanted
to let you see that because that's the
real there is a lot of clutter
decluttering it's an opportunity for you
to get out of your own way and fully
step into where you're headed now so
this is my closet I like a lot of Peaks
hoodie you I always go right to the
three steps I follow which is the sort
purge then organized so I would want to
sort so that you can know your inventory
and be able to make those outfits so
easily and then you can pull from each
side like this is my professional side
this is my everyday side but every once
in a while you label doing they're
separated you'll be able to see that
right away this is day seven that I'm
using it and I feel like a lot of the
dark spots on my face are lining up I
also like that it's kind of like a
whipped soft feeling like it feels
really light and airy but it does like
absorb into my skin and then I can put
my makeup on and the feel good guys
oh that's gross I'm already feeling
better about this because it's just less
stuff for my eyes to look at
[Music]
this is what I ended up in today it
doesn't really feel like me but I'm
trying I'm off this meeting and I did my
hair and I forgot my production oh but
wait how are you doing
it's been good I've been working on my
skin using the moisturizer from Olay I
usually have dark spots right here and
it's just feeling more even with the
Wardrobe I feel like I might need a
little bit more work I think it takes a
lot of time it has been kind of crazy
you guys I'm excited about working this
much but I realized I get on set and I
look so tired well I think I may have
something for that it's an eye job and
Olay yes and it's gonna help with your
tired eyes if you say it's good it's
good because the moisturizers worked I
trust you you got this
I've been working pretty hard at
decluttering and it feels good
that's my Zen zone still pretty Zen but
now it leads into my workspace we
organized all the crap it's all gone
this has really been helping me feel
very organized because I feel like at
home I'm ready to rock
even before I leave it's been kind of a
long week
this under-eye gel Wow feels actually
really cool all right sir Patrice how do
we think she did I am curious to see how
she did with all this stuff we gave her
I'm actually just now realizing how much
more quick I hope I know she can handle
it she's yeah I've got a really good
head on her shoulder she's ready for
this new job and whatever it takes
whoa I like that she is still playful
because that's who she is and she
doesn't feel like stiff or like she
can't be herself so literally look at
her skin glowing she's oozing and she'd
even have a moisturizer when we started
this oh my god she's really finding
herself in her space in a good way
that's gonna support her visions and her
dream she's not gonna be distracted by
all that clutter anymore I'm about to go
Patrice Gullah
it was a great meeting today I just had
a great day in general I felt good and I
still feel like me but I feel
professional I don't feel like I have to
be embarrassed when I walk into a place
yeah this was a great experience another
quarter life crisis averted
cheers to that
[Music]